hi i'm sal khan founder of the
not-for-profit khan academy and i have
some very exciting news the data is in
from our first year of the partnership
between us and the college board around
khan academy being the official practice
for the s.a.t and what we're seeing is
students who spend an average of 20
hours of practice on khan academy are
seeing roughly 115 point gain between
the psat and the sat and to put that
into perspective that's roughly twice
the point gain that students typically
see between the psat and the sat and
what's especially heartening is that
we're seeing that gain be consistent
across
gender
race and socioeconomic groups
and so this makes us feel really good
not just from the khan academy's point
of view or the college board's point of
view but just in the overall theme of
being able to help level the playing
field students take the psat they can
sync those accounts with the khan
academy khan academy software then has
the information necessary to essentially
do weak point training know where you
need practice not just in math but in
reading and writing as well and you get
that practice so that you can put your
best foot forward not just on the sat
but to be optimally prepared for college
and for life so this is exciting news
it's also just the beginning and we hope
to work with all of you students parents
teachers to further level the playing
field for college and life access